My son is having issues with parasites.
Can he take Ivermectin or fendizol with that?
I wouldn't.
So these are medications and they have side effects.
You know, just like any, we think, oh, this is just okay,
but I am very careful.
I never take an endo, okay?
So, you know, even if I'm really, really sore after a guardian,
it's like, I tell my wife, today I don't have to take two
Ivermectin or I'm not going to be able to fall asleep.
My body's going to ache so much.
And I just can't do it because it's not good for your liver.
So I try not to do it.
And I'm not saying that you can't do that.
And I'm not saying that you can't just take Ivermectin
or parasites.
But again, I would do a natural parasite cleanse.
I would use paraclyr.
I would use the, you know, the parasite cleanses in
a cell core or something.
I would do that before I would do
Ivermectin and bed is all it.
I didn't have that cancer.
And I was just trying to kill parasites.
Just because it's all over the news that it's helpful
with cancer and it's off-labeled drug or it helps with
COVID or something like that.
It doesn't mean it's like candy that we can just eat
every day.
So we should have been candy every day.
But, you know what I'm talking about?
It doesn't mean that it's just acceptable for everybody to use.
And it is not going to have any side effects.
It's just, we're being foolish.
I think if we're going to treat any medication that way.
Just like the first question, we can't even trust
what they're putting in this stuff.
Now that everybody's taking it, what are they doing?
Lacing it with stuff because everybody's taking it.
Now they've decided it's acceptable.
Once they say it's acceptable.
Okay, my trust factor instantly falls into the garbage.
So I don't trust anything that, quote unquote, they say.
So just my two cents, I would do a natural approach
before I would do the medications.